Christopher what is today's poll
question today all right go to riches
and show on Twitter to vote inspired by
our next guest Albert freer what's your
take on participation trophies no harm
keep them they suck destroy them don't
care about yeah I mean again the poll
question brought to you man man versus
food it could really be brought to you
by Breer versus trophy as we saw on his
Twitter feed before Daniel Jones of the
Giants calls in from this segment and
then we will take your calls at 8 for 4
204 rich some folks want to chime in on
the shift as well that we started our
show with but we shift our way
Dalbert prayer of mmq be calm how are
you Albert I'm alright we we've we've
we've all placed our wagers on whether
you really did snap your child's
participant participation trophy from
baseball in half or made this a
statement on how you actually felt about
a trophy that fell apart on its own
Albert you have the floor well I mean
maybe one use you know 9 or 10 or 13 or
14 maybe I'll have stronger feelings on
this but the kids for to get done
Saturday and you know I've got a
two-year-old boy too and so of course
the two-year-old steals a
four-year-old's trophy drops it it snaps
in half right okay so my wife wasn't
upset about it but my wife you know or
my wife grabbed the trophy and she get
some glue and she's got it on you know
this paper plate like you look when
you're going to anything together and
and I see it and I'm like oh well you
know through snap a selfie and so I said
hold on so watch this and I took a
picture of it and I put it up on
Instagram and you know when you're on
Instagram you always have the option
there likes I'm alone on other so yes
yeah yes and so I was like well let's
see how Twitter would react and so I hit
a little Twitter button and I put
I thought I saw rich I thought like
hashtagging there are two hashtags in
the Instagram poet's one get cut off
there were two United States on the
Instagram post one said play like a
champion the other said father of the
year now I figured play like a champion
right like in reference to a t-ball
Sophie would like tipped us off is being
sarcastic and just in case it didn't I
COO father of the year on there to make
sure people would get the joke but you
know and sometimes you know I will be
this like sometimes there are people out
there that may be looking for this sort
of thing from people and tend to be a
little over aggressive in pursuing it
when it gets up there so my
four-year-old will be that the glue by
the way didn't work just so you know
right there's an update for the glue
didn't work so I had to go buy some
epoxy we'll see if that works or not we
have been in touch with the coach too
okay so we're trying to figure out that
sort oh okay it's funny Albert that you
say that that a trophy broke and the
epoxy will have to work is I have right
here because I brought in here figuring
that epoxy would be and my show studio I
have right here broken into two pieces
my daughter's participation trophy from
soccer that is here in pieces right here
on the Rich Eisen show for Taylor Eisen
for her electric bees championship well
it's not yeah I want to point this out
to doesn't say champion does it Chris
right and you'd think that here in Los
Angeles where softer people and the rest
of air in New England with Breer say
champions on your kids t-ball trophy
Albert like I didn't actually notice
that yeah they didn't keep score which I
guess we can discuss the merits of that
no but I don't think they keep score was
before in the five and six-year-olds and
so yeah I mean he technically could have
been the champion I'm just I just can't
verify because I didn't know I yeah okay
so I'm with you at age four five and six
youth sports even seven you gotta make
sure that they have fun
but right around eight you know we get
we give the kids plaques and Pony
baseball out here so you know they got
their photograph and there's the team
photograph and it's a plaque so it's not
really a UH it's not a trophy you like
you know what I mean but at some point
you have to teach about winning and
losing I hear you oh yeah no I
absolutely agree with that like I
honestly if we're gonna be serious about
this go for it I'm the best but that's
the best lessons in sports teach you and
we all prayed played at some level
growing up I'm the best lots of sports
teach you aren't how to win it's how to
lose and how to deal with failure and so
that's why I want to talk about keeping
scoring the rest of it like you know
you'd hate to see those lessons taken
away from kids because you know
eventually you're gonna fail in life and
you gotta learn how to deal with that
and I think that you know learning how
to deal with loss at eight or nine or
ten years old is a good way to try to to
get you ready for what you're gonna face
later in life I agree there you go I
agree Albert I absolutely agree with you
but if you don't mind me saying and it's
only fitting that you would say what you
said because personally I think you need
some lessons on how to win child quite
frankly have you noticed Michigan is uh
is in the semifinals of the College
World Series I would say that's I would
say that's not way to come way to care
for the rest got it Albert we got you on
baseball
I'm basketball too so look before I let
you go I've got Daniel Jones calling in
shortly
from the Giants yes what did you what
can you interpret Pat schirmer's
comments when they broke for the summer
about the quarterback scenario there
Albert yeah I think the locker room
always knows right the locker room
always knows who the best player is and
you know especially at that position if
the best player isn't playing
it can be a problem for you and it's
because guys at other positions are cold
best players gonna fly in you know if
you're not doing that the most important
position it becomes hard to sell it
elsewhere and so I think part of our
MERS intention here was to make sure
that people knew that you know that the
best quarterback was going to play and I
think it is an affirmation that Danielle
Jones had a good five or six weeks after
the draft and had put himself in the
position to compete for a starting
quarterback job the other stretch
history tells us that guy's going to
play sooner rather than later you know
if you want to look at the history you
know really over the last 10 years
almost always a first-round quarterback
gets into real game action as a rookie
and so you know you can go through all
the different guys you know whether it
was Blake bortles a few years ago you
know more recently you know Derek Carr
like there are other guys like there are
a bunch of guys who you know we're out
there's guys who are a quote-unquote
going to be registered and it didn't
happen and so I think at the very least
you can interpret past schirmer's
comments as saying well Daniel Jones had
a really strong spring everybody in the
locker room sees it and so we've got to
give him a chance to compete just like
we would give anyone any other position
a chance to compete yeah that's why I
viewed it - and also you got a guy in
Eli who's like a Hall of Fame and a Hall
of Fame individual and you know honestly
I you know everyone wants an answer
right now and wants to get the answer
right now and I daniel Jones could wind
up being absolutely fantastic at the gig
and and that's gonna be I was saying
this for years our toughest job in New
York City was who's gonna be the closer
and shortstop after Rivera and Jeter and
that was has gone a little bit more
swimmingly than I thought whatever and
whoever fellows Eli because Eli inches
the Bell every time and he's got two
rings yep you know and and I think the
you know III think what's interesting
about to me too is by no fault of his
own daniel Jones has dealt with a really
difficult situation right off the bat
right like I mean
the jokes and all the different stuff
coming out of the draft right gentlemen
took a hit you know
but Daniel Jones kind of got caught in
the crossfire there I think what's
really interesting about it is all that
pressure you're talking about there
daniel Jones by no fault of his own had
to deal with a lot of that right away
had to deal with talking about him a
certain people talking about him a
certain way right away and so you know I
would think that that should serve him
well going forward even if it wasn't
comfortable over the last five or six
weeks to hear some of the things people
are saying about Albert I knew you
didn't break that trophy thanks for the
call you got it that's our prayers for
the mmq b mm q be calm the mmq be calm
and at Albert Brewer on Twitter for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app